c'est un interrupteur pour la façade
et du coup quand il est baissé
les lumières allumées toute la nuit en
fait je pense que c'est une aberration
parce que dans un monde à ressources
limitées le meilleur moyen de ne pas
gaspiller c'est peut-être de ne pas
consommer
de voir toutes ces lumières allumées la
nuit forcément ça nous laisse pas
indifférent on n'est pas politisé nous
ne daigne de notre collectif c'est le
sport donc c'est clairement une action
militante east mais c'est une action
citoyenne guidée par le sens
en sorte que de le faire dans les règles
aussi on ne fait pas quand ça dégrade la
vitrine quand ça se substitue à
l'éclairage public quand ces choses
d'utilité publique comme les pharmacies
la police etc confiance en soi
bienveillant et que derrière le message
soit bien reçu
passe muraille basse murray en fait
c'est quand on va taper le mur pour
chercher en hauteur en fait c'est une
prise d'élan grâce au mur
oui il est facile ben monsieur les déjà
partie on va essayer de finir avant lui
[Musique]
allez concurrence
là
mais
non ça reste en lice est dépassé salles
et 1 to mais
c'est surtout une bande de potes qui
quitte le sport qu'ils soient parcours
grimper juste on est là en tout sépare
les deux nuits c'est magnifique donc
c'est tout bénef pour nous comme tous
les jeux en fait après on repère assez
vite ou est ce qu'il faut regarder on
voit de la lumière
on cherche si la petite manette
abc voilà ça met du jeu dans ta balader
ça fait un petit geste comme ça après
peut-être il y aura il a rallumé
heureusement peut-être pas appelé qui se
diront que ça sert à rien
[Musique]
à la base la xr c'était un mouvement de
militants écologistes qui faisait ça
avec des perches un escabeau nous avec
nos techniques de parcours on s'était
dit que à un moment ça allait être un
peu plus utile pour démocratiser le
sport de le mettre dans un contexte hors
de la performance
la loi dit que ces anciennes doivent
être éteintes 2h à 6h du matin sauf que
le bâlois est rarement respectée je sais
qu'il ya une amende mais nous on n'est
pas là on joue pas le rôle d'une
autorité
par contre on est là pour envoyer un
message sachant que notre action
symbolique parce qu'on va pas être
toutes les lumières
de toutes les enseignes par contre on
sait que
derrière eux
s'il ya des réactions derrière nos
actions ça fait toujours du bien
[Musique]